j'écoutais bonjour à toutes et à tous
ici à rome j'espère que vous allez bien
donc on se retrouve pour une nouvelle
vidéo donc je suis hyper content là je
suis tout excité [ __ ] je viens de voir
qu'il y a un un teaser un petit trailer
tout petit trailer pour star wars star
wars 8 pardon qui sort en mai 2010 est
normalement donc il ya déjà un petit
trailer un petit teaser là je suis très
excité et toucher trop envie de voir ça
voilà je suis hyper content donc la nuit
dans ce nouveau festival cheney on va
commencer dans bas tout de suite on
commence au dessus je suis trop
impatient je peux plus attendre je suis
trop content là j'ai trouvé barça donc
par contre ça va être en anglais donc je
suis désolé si je comprends pas tout
même si vous ne comprenez pas tous là ça
vient de sortir à l'instant la savane
sortir l'instant j'ai j'ai sauté j'ai
pris le micro le micro le casque est
tous en lâche trop excité j'arrivais à
parler donc goa les gens ce top dans
trois deux un top
il
la loi permet à 6
et fumo months later
alors là j'ai le seul talent j'étais
trop excité et où la semaine redescendre
d'un coup c'est de voir mon visage l'ag
c'était un troll remarque production
teaser trailer trequesser
ça veut dire que c'est une fin de
tournage d'accord c'est une fin de
tournage pour 3,8 je crois que c'était
sa [ __ ] je suis grave déçu là je te
fais un truc de ouf
bon en même temps il fait 40 secondes
mais quand même je photos d au moins un
petit truc et touche tu es trop excité
bain
la libye
je crois que j'attendais trop un trailer
en fait bon bah c'est pas grave écouter
bon mois s'annoncent une fin de tournage
pour star wars 8
c'est plutôt pas mal je suis plutôt
content j'espère qu'on aura d'autres et
leur j'espère pouvoir vous faire rater
fait escale reaction lâché un petit peu
un petit peu triste
là j'étais au top et là ça d'un coup
j'attends d'avoir une petite image du
film août mais en même temps c'est
logique il sort dans un an à peu près un
an et les deux mois environ
donc c'est pour ça qu'on m'a écoutée en
tout cas j'espère que cette courte vidéo
vous aura plu
n'hésitez pas à liker commenté vidéo et
de venir à la un lac intérieur si ce
n'est pas déjà fait un bond à la voix
n'hésitez pas à liker pour cette cette
déception du ouf
à très bientôt je suis un petit peu déçu
je vous fais des gros bisous pas écouté
ses terres rock
ciao tout le monde
lors de six oiselets